lisa what's going on we have a son who's
profoundly disabled
okay and you know throughout his life
we've just kind of met
step by step what we need to do for him
and
now we're getting older i'm in my 60s
and so we're facing that
i kind of call it the final challenge
where we have to
you know find i'm going to start crying
already that's okay it's all right this
one's heavy
trying to you know find a place for him
when we're gone
yep and that's my my
problem right now is i you know like
we've
gotten guardianship of him and we've got
a special needs trust for him and we
taking care of our wills and um we even
took care of our funerals and all those
things and so now this is like okay now
we need to start finding a place um
first of all that will accept him
he's profound so there's not a lot of
choices
and um so i'm just trying to and i know
there's lots of other moms that will
are dealing with this as well so i just
kind of don't know the steps to
prepare myself for you know taking him
there and walking away one day
or um and also for him
you know how do we tell the kids you
know we have to take you this place one
day
yeah does he does he have the cognitive
capacity to understand that conversation
i i know i'm quite sure he doesn't okay
he's profoundly um you know the best
they could tell maybe like a two to
three year old level
okay uh maybe um but
he does know you know he knows us he's
been loved his whole life
he goes with us where we go you know and
he just wouldn't i can't even think if
he wasn't taken care of you know
and yeah you just hear all those horror
stories of
people in nursing homes and things that
happen and i just well
but there are also some really great
ones right you know that
know that yeah hey this is this isn't a
data conversation
this is a mom and a baby boy
conversation right right
right um so let's clear the the
the big piece let's clear the clear the
the most important thing nobody will
ever love that little boy like you do
ever
right right right and he
won the freaking lottery when he got you
as his mom
thank you god one two how old is he
he's 29 29 he
won he won
he got you which is so cool lisa
so i wish i could help here
there is no way there's no
preparatory thing there's no exercise
program or yoga class you can take
to make that singular drop off
easy yeah it's not it's gonna be
real real hard and it's gonna be right
you know what i mean yeah i mean it has
to be
it has to be right and there will get to
be a moment when
not that someone's ever going to outlove
you no chance
will anyone out love you but there will
come a time
when somebody has more skills more
um technology more mobility
that can help him serve him better than
you can
and that's okay right
right and you can sleep and not knowing
i out love all those suckers
they can pick him up and move him and
take care of his needs
i always love him more so haha right all
that's going to be true
and one of the deep deep deep pains deep
pains of
loving somebody who's with a profound
disability
is um and it's to say it's it's similar
as you mentioned to navigating life with
a child right when a child's got to go
in for some sort of treatment
you can't explain what why this pain
is this way i remember lisa i remember
her the first time my first little boy i
was trying to be super dad and i'm not
going to be like the other dads i'm
going with all these new appointments
and i took my little and he may have
been six months and my wife was with me
she by the way knew this was happening
and i didn't
we took him in and this to this doctor's
office were hugging and playing
and he's cooing and this angel of death
came in with two two uh
syringes like two giant needles in my
head they're like nine inches long they
probably weren't
and she double blasted him in each leg
same time
and he looked at me like dad
you like you're that old like a2 brute
like
you yeah you and then he screamed
i still have that scream in my soul i
have not gone back my wife said you're
not welcome back
because i wanted to take that nurse and
oh it was not going to end well right
here's the thing you can't explain it
it's a it's a it's the thing that has to
happen
and it's hard because love sucks
sometimes
right right right the price of love is
that pain
and what you're gonna have to constantly
pull yourself back to it's the same
thing you've had to do your whole life
right have you struggled with bouts of
guilt throughout your life
no i really have it good for you dude
you're
you're already a gangster lisa that's
awesome
man one of the most common things when i
talk to parents of special needs kids is
that that guilt like somehow
you know this is on me right good for
you that's awesome
so yeah here's what you need to do you
need to
prep for this moment how how soon is it
how soon are you thinking about a home
once i mean i just i just you know i
think it was
you know two like two weeks ago we just
went ahead and got our funerals all
planned and
you know paid for and taken care of and
i started thinking
you know i really need to start getting
him
you know start thinking of that because
i know there's waiting lists and
especially for the good places and so i
need to start making those phone calls
and i've
picked up the phone to call a place his
caseworker had said would
would be a good nursing home and i just
started crying
but i'll call you back hey you know what
that that happens
that happens all the time yeah it does
um i want you and your husband to
read a book together called finding a
finding meaning by david kessler
we'll link to it in the show notes here
it's a book on grief
but more importantly it's a book on what
happens on the other side of grief
and david kessler is the is the guru
when it comes to grieving
and the the book not to spoil alert here
but he has he's been the guy who's
called into
to hard situations forever that's just
been his thing he's the guy he was
studied under elizabeth kubler-ross he's
the guy
and then he lost his
20-something-year-old son
and a profound moment in the book is
when he talks about i want to go back
and hug every parent i ever talked to
about grief because i had no idea
right but then he talks on the back end
of finding meaning so what are some
things when you can't lift your son
anymore
when you can't get him up the ramp
anymore when you can't feed him
in the way that he needs to be taken
care of anymore and you've got to
surrender that service part not the love
but surrender that service part to
somebody else where will you then find
meaning
how extraordinary would it be if you
opened up a free service because it
sounds like you guys have taken care of
your finances in a way that is really
gonna honor your son
honor your your last years what if you
open up a free service
to talk to new moms and dads who just
found out
they are giving birth to a son or a
daughter with profound needs
what if you led a small group to walk
moms and dads what this is going to be
like
and suddenly that angst you feel that
somebody else is caring for your son
doing those things that you've spent the
last 30 years doing
you're able to channel that into serving
new families who are going to be walking
this journey that you and your husband
have walked so carefully and so well
and that's just one example that came to
me off top my head but
it becomes about when you're 65 and 70
and 75 and 80 and 85
how are you going to make meaning of
that hurt how are you going to make
meaning of that loss of connection there
and how you're going to continue to
honor your son and love your son
in just a new and unique way right but
you're doing all the right things
there's not an easy way to drive away
there's not
there's not an easy way to explain to
somebody with with limited cognitive
capacity
that this is the best right thing even
though it's going to be hard
even though you know he's going to want
to be with you
even though you know he recognizes you
it's going to be hard
you and your husband are going to need
each other and then you're going to need
to go make meaning you're going to let
meaning come to you
and you're talking about legacy changing
family tree changing meaning
when you get involved in the lives of
other folks in that way so thank you for
your heart lisa i wish i could just snap
my fingers and make it happen
but whoo man